you should clean your wounds with
rubbing alcohol
ouch
slap a choking person on the back
yeah not really working after getting
stabbed take out the sharp object from
the body
this is from movies um this is stupid
don't do this
hi my name is randy lee i'm a paramedic
here in new york city and i've been
working ems for 11 years hi my name is
lorena concepcion martinez i am a
paramedic here in new york city also
with randy for the past 19 years and
today we'll be debunking myths about
first aid ready let's go if someone gets
a concussion keep them awake this is an
old wives tale they associated someone
having a concussion and going into a
coma and not being able to wake up so
that's why they used to say to keep
everybody awake now
we figured out that the sleeping does
not cause the coma when someone has a
concussion it is considered a type of
tbi traumatic brain injury you do want
to monitor them though you want to make
sure there's no deficit no changes so
things you're going to be looking out
for would be slurred speech vomiting
unsteady gait which means you're like
wobbly when you walk a little dizzy yeah
you don't want any of that so if you
think that's a problem and it's not
self-resolving then yeah take them to
the hospital let them do a cat scan let
them make sure that the patient's not
having an internal bleed in their brain
you should put something into the mouth
of someone having a seizure
negative this is a major no-no this is
another old wives tale of people
thinking that the patient having a
seizure was gonna swallow their tongue
it's more muscle spasms and clenching of
the jaw so you don't really have to
worry about the patient swallowing the
tongue or anything along those lines
that whole time you're talking i tried
to swallow my tongue i couldn't do it
so it's not true when someone's having a
seizure they're having these uh
fasciculations this tightening of the
muscles what'll happen is they'll clinch
to their jaw and if you put something in
their mouth they'll break their teeth
they'll break their jaw back your finger
off yeah don't do it you also want to
let the seizure pass you want to make
sure once they've stopped you can roll
them on their side and just kind of be
supportive until ems arrives to help
most seizures will resolve themselves
after say 30 seconds to a minute but
if you have something called status
epilepticus the patient will end up
having continuous seizures which will
affect their breathing that point is
where you need that advanced medical
care advanced life support paramedics
like randy and i to come in and give
medications to actually try to subside
the seizures and transport the patient
to the hospital as quickly as possible
slap a choking person on the back this
myth does come from how you treat an
infant or a child that is choking
because we do back slaps as we call them
in an infant or a child but in adult you
want to emphasize on doing the heimlich
maneuver wait hold on i have a thing for
this so imagine
this guy's choking we're gonna try the
back slap thing
yeah not really working
if you come across a person choking try
to encourage them to keep coughing so
randy here is gonna show you the
universal choking sign which is
this is smiling clearly but you know
they'll be like this that's the
universal choking sign do not i stress
do not give them anything in the drink
you want them to keep coughing until
they clear that airway and if it becomes
completely obstructed that they can't
get any air movement they can't speak
and they start turning blue it's time
for that heimlich and definitely 911.
depending on who you follow the protocol
for treating choking is a little bit
different the american red cross
recommends five back blows followed by
five abdominal thrusts and repeat but
lorena and i follow the american heart
association protocols so we go straight
to the abdominal thrusts when you're
doing the abdominal thrust like the old
name of the maneuver you're gonna make a
fist so this goes right to the navel
just slightly above you're gonna do a
pulling up motion like a j i'm gonna
squeeze with a lot of force
so unlike the movies and stuff this
actually takes a lot of effort you can't
just do it in one shot you're going to
be really tired doing this and it's
probably going to hurt the person as
well but it's better than them choking
to death
there you go when you do this please
make sure to keep your head to the side
because if not the patient will bang you
on your nose and you might end up with a
bloody nose boom
always suck the venom out of a snake
bite i'm sorry
um i don't know how to answer this
properly it's ill-advised to ever have
an answer in her life where sucking
something out is like your go-to thing
if you drop food coloring into a cup of
water it's very difficult
to get it back
together it's impossible to get it all
out so the same applies for venom on a
snake bite once it's in it's in the
bloodstream it's gonna circulate so it's
really not gonna do much the other thing
is stay away from putting any kind of
tourniquet it's gonna create more damage
than what it's gonna help if someone's
gonna be bit by a venomous snake sucking
on the wound you're gonna get such a
minimal amount out it's not going to do
anything and then you leave them exposed
to infection because
your mouth is probably dirty if you
encounter someone who's had a venomous
keyword venomous snake bite you
definitely want to call
as soon as possible and get that patient
to the hospital you want to go to a
venom center or a bite center and it's
particularly a hospital that has all
kinds of anti-venoms antidotes for this
kind of incident cpr requires mouth to
mouth cpr does not require mouth to
mouth there are procedures of just doing
chest compressions that allow you to
make sure that blood circulating through
the whole body to get oxygenated blood
to the brain that's the goal it buys you
time for us paramedics to show up a
couple years back cpr was required
mouth-to-mouth but do you really want to
put your mouth on a total complete
stranger the american heart association
and everyone else who teaches cpr have
been doing a strong emphasis on hands
only it eliminates the transmissions of
any communicable diseases or anything
along all those lines to do cpr properly
you're going to want to expose the chest
down
so you have access to the bare chest
palm your hand it's under the chest
you're going to wrap your fingers around
each other and then you're just going to
push straight down
for an adult it's about two inches or so
but basically just going to keep that
going on for 100 beats per minute there
is a song that we utilize all the time
historically we use staying alive
staying alive staying alive so when
you're doing cpr the main thing you want
to just maintain is that those
compressions are going to be consistent
anytime you stop that threshold goes
down it causes a huge amount of
detriments to the body you got to start
doing it immediately you got like six
minutes before you have irreversible
damage to the brain so start cpr quick
give them a good shot after getting
stabbed take out the sharp object from
the body
this is from movies um this is stupid
don't do this do not remove it you will
cause a lot more tissue damage and cause
a lot more bleeding so please
i stress this please do not remove it
leave it in place you should stabilize
it so it doesn't go wiggling around
inside because any kind of movement to
the foreign object will create more
damage it's great movies though it's
hysterical drama effect it's just like
oh why no i don't get it yeah
you have to be medically trained to use
a defibrillator it'll make you feel more
confident but you really don't what you
see out there they're not actually
defibrillators like you see in the
movies paddles and all that craziness
they don't let's show them okay so this
is an aed this is an automatic external
defibrillator a defibrillator basically
shocks the heart all municipal buildings
have these in every location so the best
thing about defibrillators is that
anyone can use them all you have to do
is open it up and press the power button
and it will literally tell you
step by step what needs to be done open
it up adult mode remove all clothing
from patient's chest did you pull the
red handle sure doing pictures on pads
there are photos to show you exactly
where you're supposed to put these
things on you want to use this as
quickly as possible once you know the
person is in cardiac arrest if the
person is unresponsive but you're not
sure you still want to use this and put
it on the patient's chest if the
patient's alive it will tell you not to
shock analyzing heart rhythm provide
chest compressions to the beat and
continue cpr don't be afraid to ask
someone to go get the defibrillator or
the aed put butter on a burn to heal it
what are you a piece of toast and that
would be a no
you do not put butter on a burn it's
going to trap the heat and ultimately
the heat is going to keep radiant so it
will continue to burn basically you want
to stop the burning process no matter
what it is it could be a first degree
burn to a third degree burn you want to
just eliminate that right so just cool
water keyword cool not cold you just
want to keep it clean sterile and cool
it down seek medical care if you get
frostbite on your hands rub them
together to warm them up
ooh
i would say you don't want to do that i
went from hot to cold yeah we did go
from hot to cold if you do have
frostbite on your fingertips or toes
which is usually where it starts you
never want to rub them the friction will
cause more damage to the skin tissue and
the cells below it so you want to warm
them up slowly coming into a warmer
environment taking off any wet clothing
on it and just gradually warming it up
so how do you know the difference though
between just being
cold and having frostbite you'll have
this waxy type deal on your hands your
hands are going to be a little more
puffy basically you're going to be
blistered up imagine like just a really
bad burn except the opposite because
it's cold once you cross that frostbite
threshold it's something that you
definitely need to go to the emergency
room to be treated by a physician
because the amount of damage that can be
done by treating it incorrectly can be
irreversible you should clean your
wounds with rubbing alcohol
ouch
i'm sorry this is painful just to think
about it and that would be a no rubbing
alcohol is gonna be very painful so
please stay away from rubbing alcohol
just simple soap and water if you have
antibacterial soap even better it cleans
it sure but why go through the trouble
of like actually hurting yourself
essentially you also want to make sure
that the wound stays moist and alcohol
has this drying property that's not
going to be conducive to healing anyway
keep it simple soap and water if it's an
abrasion a simple cut a day or two with
a band-aid is always good just to
control whatever bleeding you have
that's the main key you want to do the
triple antibiotic and let it get free
air the air will actually help stimulate
scabbing and scabbing is a natural
barrier that the body creates so it can
heal and regenerate wow cardiac arrest
and a heart attack are the same thing
they're not the same thing cardiac
arrest
means that your heart stopped they are
no longer conscious they are no longer
breathing and their heart is no longer
beating so this is where cpr comes into
play heart attack you have an occlusion
in your heart the heart is starving for
air causing the chest pain you have the
ability to get to the hospital you'll
have shortness of breath you'll be
diaphoretic which means really really
sweaty all classic signs of a heart
attack not everyone will have the same
symptoms so remember call 9-1-1 for
either one if you witness a drug
overdose put the person in the shower or
bath um no because one you have no idea
what the person overdosed on any kind of
dramatic change to someone's temperature
will throw the hemostasis of the body
all out of whack what does that mean
your body has a regulation of
temperature you can't go into any
extremes quickly yeah it just makes
getting the patient out and treated a
lot more difficult if they're like in a
bathtub and wet and we as paramedics
carry stuff such as narcan to help
counteract yes any narcotic overdoses
specifically for opioid overdoses but we
also have other drugs that help with
other types of overdoses so please make
sure don't lie about what you took that
makes it way harder for us because if
you took drug a and you tell us it was
drug b we're going to go the wrong route
and the treatment will get skewed and
then we'll figure it out eventually but
then we have to backtrack and then go
that route it's it's very dangerous so
no shower this is
debunked look at all these myths the
intention is there everyone wants to
help somebody else that's great but
you're going to want to get a little
education on your back end take a first
day of class you don't have to go to a
level emt and paramedic and who knows
you might be
somebody's hero one day